LOOKING FOR.
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE IT.
AND HERE AT FOX EVERYONE
DOES, TRUST ME.
CREDIT CARD DEBT IS
EXPLODING IN THIS COUNTRY.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, AMERICANS
AS A WHOLE OWN MORE THAN A
TRILLION DOLLARS JUST TO
CREDIT CARD COMPANIES.
THAT'S 8600 BUCKS FOR EVERY
HOUSEHOLD IN THIS COUNTRY,
MORE THAN 3 GRAND FOR EVERY
SINGLE MAN, WOMAN, AND CHILD
IN AMERICA.
INCLUDING BABIES.
THAT'S JUST CREDIT CARDS.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ALSO
HAVE STUDENT LOANS, HOME
LOANS, CAR LOANS, PLENTY OF
OTHER DEBT.
ARE WE REACHING A TIPPING
POINT FOR DEBT AND WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF THE ECONOMY
ENTERS ANOTHER DOWNTURN NOT
THAT THAT WOULD EVER HAPPEN.
HAWKINS CHIEF
MACROSTRATEGIST AT TAMITICA.
TELL ME HOW TO PRONOUNCE
THAT LENORE.
>> TAMATICA.
>> Tucker: TOO MANY VOWELS
FOR ME.
RESEARCH.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
I'M GLAD YOU ARE LAUGHING
BECAUSE THIS IS A TERRIFYING
SUBJECT PARTICULARLY THE
CREDIT CARD DEBT SOMETHING
EVERYONE CAN RELATE TO AND
UNDERSTAND HOW IT WORKS IF
YOU ARE A CONSUMER.
THESE LEVELS SEEM VERY HIGH
TO ME.
ARE THEY.
>> THEY ARE VERY HIGH.
WHAT'S EVEN MORE CONCERNING
IS THE PACE AT WHICH WE ARE
ACCUMULATING IT.
AND, IN FACT, THE LAST THREE
MONTHS OF 2017 CONSUMERS
RACKED UP CREDIT CARD DEBT
AT A FASTER PACE THAN IN THE
PAST 30 YEARS.
SO FASTER THAN EVEN IN THE
GREAT RECESSION.
>> Tucker: IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE STORIES
THAT IS NEVER COVERED BUT IT
OUGHT TO BE.
HERE YOU HAVE SOME OF THE
BIGGEST COMPANIES IN THE
WORLD GETTING KIDS ON CREDIT
CARDS IN COLLEGE, CHARGING
RATES THAT BANKS WOULD NEVER
CHARGE.
I'M GOING TO CHARGE -- I HAD
MY -- THE BP VISA CARD,
WHAT'S THE INTEREST RATE?
28.2% -- 28% INTEREST.
ISN'T SOMEONE SUPPOSED TO
BE.
IT'S SHOCKING ACTUALLY.
IT'S USURY.
ILLEGAL IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
WHY IS IT HAPPENING HERE AND
NO ONE IS SAYING ANYTHING?
>> BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T SEEM
TO HAVE MUCH OF A CHOICE
THESE DAYS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HOURLY
EARNINGS HAVE BEEN, DECADE
AFTER DECADE AFTER DECADE
THEY HAVE BEEN GROWING AT
SLOWER AND SLOWER PACE.
PEOPLE ARE BARELY MAKING
ENDS MEET.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PAST SIX
OUT OF THE PAST SEVEN MONTHS
HOURLY EARNINGS HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN EITHER FLAT OR
THEY HAVE FALLEN.
PEOPLE AREN'T REALLY MAKING
MUCH MONEY.
THEN YOU LOOK AT SPENDING.
SPEND SOMETHING STILL
GROWING PRETTY FAST.
INCOME ISN'T GROWING REALLY
FAST.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
TAKE THESE CREDIT CARDS AND
GET DESPERATE.
>> Tucker: THIS IS AN AGE
OLD PROBLEM WHEN THE MAFIA
USED TO DO THIS IN IMMIGRANT
NEIGHBORHOOD BASICALLY THE
EXACT SAME THING CREDIT
CARDS ARE DOING.
THE FEDS CRACKED DOWN ON IT
AND SENT THEM TO PRISON
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO DO THAT WHY DO WE LET THE
CREDIT CARD COMPANIES DO THE
SAME THING.
>> I THINK PART OF WHAT WE
ARE SEEING IS THAT A LOT OF
THE FINANCIAL SERVICES HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING TO MAKE
MONEY EVERYWHERE BECAUSE WE
HAVE HAD HAD INTEREST RATES
PUSHED DOWN SO, SO, SO LOW.
THAT DOESN'T GIVE THOSE
BANKS MUCH ROOM TO WORK TO
MAKE MONEY.
THEY BORROW -- THEY TAKE
MONEY FROM YOU INTO THE
CHECKING ACCOUNT AND LEND IT
OUT LIKE A MORTGAGE OR
SOMETHING.
THOSE RATES HAVE BEEN SO LOW
THAT IT'S BEEN TOUGH FOR
THEM TO MAKE MONEY.
THEY HAVE GOTTEN DESPERATE
AND GONE OUT FURTHER AND
FURTHER INTO THESE KIND OF
EDGY ACTIVITIES.
JUST TO TRY TO MAKE MONEY.
>> Tucker: PREYING ON THE
WEAK.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Tucker: YOU SAID LOW
INTEREST RATES.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
FED POLICY.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY GO UP
AS THEY ARE GOING TO?
>> YEAH, WELL, YOUR CREDIT
CARD PAYMENTS ARE GOING TO
GROUP A LOT HIGHER AS WELL.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE GOING
FASTER AND FASTER.
LOOK AT WHAT ALL THIS DEBT
THAT IS OUTSTANDING AND YOUR
PAYMENTS EVERY MONTH.
EVEN IF YOU DON'T ADD
ANYTHING MORE ON TO YOUR